we have a remarkable paucity of ability
to imagine what a positive end of life
experience would look like we can only
imagine death and suffering and and its
avoidance
that's about the that's about the the
brightest we can get is oh I hope I die
quickly
you know I'm hope I'm hit by a truck or
died in my sleep and I don't suffer if I
ask people what what a good death looks
like for them they'll often say you know
I don't want to suffer and I don't want
to be a burden to my family you know I I
don't want to die in pain I don't want
to die gasping for breath doc I don't
want to you know die lying in my own
filth I don't want to end up in a
nursing home you know and I don't want
to be a burden to my family if you think
about it it's as if our vision of the
the good death was a photographic
negative if there's nothing there
there's no tone or texture or color it's
as if it was a hole bordered by the
things that we fear that is is the main
problem death feels like it's falling
off a cliff and and similarly dying and
death are equated we often use the two
words interchangeably in reality as hard
and as I wanted as it is dying is a part
of living and it has it has its own
intrinsic challenges risks certainly but
also its potential value for many people
the reality is that this time of life we
call dying is often an exceedingly
important time in their lives and their
families lives but our inability to
imagine is really a limiting factor you
know we know if you only know what you
want to avoid you don't you still don't
have a direction toward which to head
and and so I think it's really important
not as it almost sometimes seems
unseemly to talk about people we know
who have died well but I submit it's
culturally critically important to
explore
the stories of real people who have in
their own words or their own experience
died well because it provides us with
some cultural orientation a diversity of
positive experience toward which we
could begin to imagine a path ahead that
for for ourselves and our families feels
like something of value
you know morally and and tangibly and
culturally of value despite the inherent
sadness that that this time entails
oh boy um the proverbial good question
you know art buchwald recently died well
he was a hospice patient interestingly
went to hospice care thinking he was
dying in a in a few days two weeks
ended up living I don't know 15 months
graduated from hospice care wrote a
best-seller wally was a hospice patient
I think that's pretty good but also if
you read his book talks about the
importance of this time in in from my
perspective there were discernible
developmental tasks that he was able to
accomplish reviewing his life
completing relationships telling his
stories sort of making some inner peace
with the the reality that his life was
coming to a close and be a being able to
look forward into a future where he
would not be physically present all of
those sorts of things
you